>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Guy Lamolinara: Our
next panel will be speaking
about accessibility, the
panels' accessibility matters,
reaching readers
with disabilities.
And the moderator of our
panel is Laura Bailet--
Bailet, excuse me.
She is a Library of
Congress Literacy Awards,
Advisory Board Member, and she
is the Chief Academic Officer
of Kaplan Early Learning
Company.
Please welcome Laura
Bailet [applause].
>> Laura Bailet: Thank you.
Thank you everyone.
Good afternoon.
The focus of our panel today is
on the millions of Americans,
both children and adults,
who struggle with reading.
The Washington Post ran an
article on November 1st,
2016 that was entitled
"Hiding in plain sight:
The adult literacy crisis."
Trouble with reading truly
is a hidden disability.
The majority of people in this
category have no outward signs
of a problem, and they're
typically quite intelligent.
They're also highly
motivated to keep others
from knowing that
they can't read.
Somebody on an earlier panel
mentioned the same associated
with being a struggling reader
and that's a huge issue,
the shame and embarrassment.
So this is not something that
they share freely with friends,
with co-workers, with educators,
with their health providers,
and their own family may not
even recognize the extent
of the problem.
So many people in the public
at large simply aren't aware
that a problem this big exists.
Our panel today is going to
share some insights on Americans
who struggle with reading
for a variety of reasons
and also talk-- will talk
about the types of programs
and technology that can
help them gain access
to printed materials.
So I have a couple of slides
just with some basic statistics
on the scope and impact of
reading struggles for children
and for adults in
the United States.
The first two slides
are an infographic
from the National Center
on Learning Disabilities.
We're not going to go
through all the statistics,
but basically one in five
American children struggles
with a significant learning
or attention challenge,
and the vast majority of them
do struggle with reading.
Learning to read is a
challenging task for the brain.
So we shouldn't really
be surprise
that so many people
struggle with it,
but nonetheless this
is a problem which--
with which nationally,
we're really honestly not
making very good progress.
And it's important to understand
that the majority of children
who struggle with reading
unfortunately today grow
into adults who are still
struggling with reading.
And let's see.
This is-- this slide
is from ProLiteracy,
the adult literacy
education organization.
They do fantastic work.
Proliteracy.org is
their website.
And you can see here
about 36 million adults
in the United States cannot
read at a third grade level.
But it's estimated that
up to 50% of adults
in the United States cannot read
and comprehend a book written
at the eight grade level.
Fifty percent, I mean
that's a lot of people.
And we know that
children of parents
who are poor readers
have a higher probability
of being a poor reader
themselves.
There's the genetic component.
Dyslexia for example is
very strongly inherited.
If an adult has dyslexia, each
of their children has a 30
to 50% chance of
having dyslexia.
But then if you're
an adult poor reader,
you're probably not going to
surround yourself with books
and other printed
materials in your home.
You're probably not going to
model reading for pleasure
or information for
your children.
And you're probably not going
to read very many books
with your children.
And so, this is a major
intergenerational challenge.
So now, I'm going to turn
things over to Kristen Fernekes,
and she's going to talk about
people with reading challenges
as a result of physical
disabilities and the services
that the Library of
Congress offers to them.
So Kristen.
>> Kristen Fernekes:
Should I come up there--
>> Laura Bailet: If you
want you can stay seated
or you can go up
there and stand.
>> Kristen Fernekes: I think
I'm just going to stay here.
>> Laura Bailet:
All right, do it.
>> Kristen Fernekes: Thank
you so much for having me.
I really, really appreciate it.
The group with whom I
work here at the Library
of Congress is the National
Library Service for the Blind
and Physically Handicapped.
We refer to it as NLS because
we have quite a long name.
NLS began in 1931 to
serve specifically adult
who were blind.
Over a period of time, over,
you know, the more than 85 years
that we've been around,
we've evolved our services
over a period of time
to reach a larger
and larger group of people.
So we serve people who are both
blind and visually impaired,
people who have physical
disabilities that prevent them
from being able to hold a book.
And to a lesser extent, we serve
individuals who have dyslexia
and other issues that may
prevent having accessibility
to regular print materials.
NLS serves people through
absolute spectacular network
of libraries around the country,
every state, Guam, Puerto Rico,
who-- to whom we serve by
providing them with materials.
So the types of materials
that we provide are braille,
e-braille, audio books, and then
of course we do have a download
service which is of course
in keeping with-- how a lot
of people are accessing
materials right now.
In addition to books, which of
course there's a lot of ways
that you can get audio books,
but we also provide magazines,
guides, things that you
wouldn't necessarily think
of for individuals who have
trouble reading print materials,
things like tax guides,
nutrition guides,
and so on and so forth.
So that puts us in a position
of being somewhat unique.
We're very proud
of our collection,
which at this point is hundreds
of thousands, over
200,000 pieces.
We also provide music scores and
music instructional materials
and so on and so forth.
So we're trying to fill-- think
of void where we want to take
into consideration that
there's a lot of people
that just have trouble
with what's available
from a print perspective, and
so we're constantly looking
at where does need exists and
then trying to address them.
Increasingly, the
individuals that we're serving
with aging [inaudible] and
so on and so forth are people
who may not have been
blind their entire life
but have decreasing
capacity seeing.
So we know that that
number is going up.
And recently we have been--
we've launched a pretty
extensive outreach campaign
to make sure that people
are aware of these services
because they are provided free.
And we want to make sure
that people can read.
>> Laura Bailet: Great,
thank you so much.
So I'm really intrigued
about e-braille.
So we'll have to come
back and you have
to tell me how that works.
>> Kristen Fernekes: Yes.
>> Laura Bailet: And now Dr.
Elsa Cardenas-Hagan is going
to talk a little bit more about
individuals with dyslexia,
and she also has
a lot of expertise
on dual language learners
and the multiple challenges
they face with learning to read
and becoming lifelong readers.
So Elsa.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
Yes, thank you.
>> Laura Bailet: And
there are your slides.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
What do you--
>> Laura Bailet: Yes,
that's the remote,
so the green will advance.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
Thank you.
Good afternoon and thank you for
sticking with us this afternoon.
I'm Elsa Cardenas-Hagan and
I am an English learner.
So I understand the
experience of an English learner
and during my time was when
there was no such thing
as bilingual education
and where we were punished
if we used our native
language in the school ground
and in the lunch room.
And so, you know, as a
young girl, being terrified
to speak your home language
and then not realizing
that your home language is
such a beautiful language
and such a beautiful
thing and I didn't realize
that until middle school
because in middle school,
that is when you take
foreign language.
And all of a sudden, I
could shine as they look
at what I know and look
at my culture and look
at the things that I know.
But it was like, OK, hide
who you in these early years
but now no, we will
not hide who we are.
And so a beautiful thing is
that we now have available
to children-- you
know, when I heard
that somebody is saying
I'm an ESL specialist,
English as a second language
specialist, and that's great
because there's less than 3% of
them in our whole United States,
less than 3% and yet we're
the fastest growing population
in our schools.
And so, you know,
we talk about--
you know, we want
to be prepared.
We want to reach these students.
We want to reach, you know, all
our African-American population.
We want to know about the
culture and the language
so that they will want
to be responsive to us,
so that they will
want to be engaged
and enthusiastic about learning.
And I hope Benita is still
here because I have my little--
there she is, my own
dedication to Barbara Bush.
And unfortunately
Benita accepted this
but I was giving a speech in
Houston and talking about all
of our reading reform efforts
and about how, you know,
I lived in one of the
poorest communities
of the whole United States
for a middle size city.
And despite that, through
our efforts, you know,
we've been able to-- and
we know it's a 100% frame
reduced length.
We feed them breakfast
and lunch and we have
after school programs that,
you know, also give dinner.
But we keep them there, you
know, to do the extra things,
you know, the arts and the
music and the books and reading.
But one of the things when I
gave a speech, I had so wanted
to meet Mrs. Barbara Bush.
And I was in Houston and
I didn't get to meet her
because there was like a
thousand people that day
and she was there
in the audience.
And so I went back to my own
community and I thought oh,
I missed the chance
to, you know,
at least great a
former first lady.
How cool would that be?
Well, I get a phone call
at my office and says,
it's Mrs. Barbara
Bush on the line.
And I was like, hello,
is that you Juanito,
playing a joke on me, you know.
Because I talked
about how I didn't get
to meet the first lady.
They go, no, for real,
this is Mrs. Bush.
And then she says, you go girl,
you blew me away and I'm going
to have you come to my
celebration of reading
in Houston, and you're going to
tell about the works that you do
and you're going
to write a speech.
And I'm like, Mrs. Bush,
I don't write speeches.
I just-- I'm a storyteller
and I tell the story of what--
you know, the work that we do.
She was, no, you're going
to write your speech.
So I'm like, yes, ma'am.
So I wrote that speech.
I'm like, who are the
other speakers by the way?
She goes, oh, you know,
H. W. and George W.
and [inaudible] all
this, Mrs. Baker.
And I was like, oh my God.
So I write the speech
and I send it to her.
And she calls me back
and she goes, well,
let's talk a little bit
more about your speech.
I'm like, yes ma'am.
And she goes, you know,
you mentioned George W.,
don't mention him, you know.
And she goes, this is
nothing about the Bush's.
It's about what you did in your
local community and nothing
about the governor of our
state and how he helped you.
And I'm like, yes ma'am.
And I said, well, while
I got you on the line,
I need a little bit more
money and I know you're going
to raise millions of dollars
that evening, so do you mind
if I talk about children
also with dyslexia
and I would have a dream that in
one of the poorest communities
that we would have an expert on
every campus in our city to work
with these children who are
English learners, who, you know,
have these disabilities, you
know, these hidden disabilities
that no one knows and
we just weave around.
And she goes, well, how
much are you needing, right?
And so I tell her the
amount and she says,
you may put that
in there, you know.
And I'm like, OK.
So that evening, I get there
and Benita knows
exactly what happened.
So I get there and I gave my
speech and I kind of weave
in there that we're
still working.
And at the end of my speech,
Mrs. Barbara Bush comes up
and she goes, ladies
and gentlemen,
I have a huge surprise
for Dr. Cardenas-Hagan,
here's your check,
no questions asked.
I about fainted.
Actually I screamed
and jumped, but anyway.
And she says, I trust
you to do the job.
And so two years later-- and I
wanted to follow up with you,
I was able to report
back to her and said,
I have some very good news.
Mrs. Bush, I have
good news to share.
We have a dyslexia
therapist in every campus
of our city in every school.
And I'm here today to tell
you [applause]-- so between--
that was between the years
of 2011 and 2013 and I'm here
to tell you in 2018,
we still have that.
>> Laura Bailet: Wow,
that great, that's great.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
We keep sustainability.
>> Laura Bailet:
Sustainability, that's huge.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: And
so, through this work --
and I say, you know, Mrs. Bush
cared very much about, you know,
all people that they
would be literacy--
and that they would achieve
literacy because she had
such a love of literacy.
And also I had personal
experience with, you know,
a child who had difficulty
in these--
those early years with literacy.
And so I'm here today to talk
to you about these children,
about what Laura
here is telling you
about that hidden
disability, that being dyslexia
and what goes around, and
I am the Vice President
of the International
Dyslexia Association.
And so, we are on a mission to
really promote what we want,
a term to be used today
called structured literacy.
And that's a term that
we want to really promote
as here we have these
students who were so bright,
so intelligent, nothing
to do with intelligence
but they struggle
with these, you know,
skills of how do you read,
how does reading work.
And as we look at this and as
we see in this, Laura mentioned
to you the majority of children
in special education
services are there
because of a reading disability,
and we will tell you 15 to 20%
of those kids have dyslexia.
And as we look at this, we see,
what are the issues with them?
So, one of the primary issues
is that they have trouble just
with the simple things of being
able to process those sounds.
And, you know, I'm a Spanish
speaker so we don't have
as many sounds in our language
as you do in yours, you know.
Some will say 44 to
46 sounds and we have
about half of that many sounds.
And so, just that ability
to process those sounds.
And, you know, a lot of research
into exactly where that is
in the brain, Heschl's gyrus,
the left angular gyrus.
And if you don't have that,
then how are you going
to put those letters
and sounds together
for those early literacy skills.
Most kids can read and they
don't need these foundational
skills but dyslexic children
will not be able to do it
without learning how
does reading work.
And they try to trick you
because they're so smart
and they depend upon
their visual memory.
And finally, you know,
things fall apart
by the time all this reading
to learn or when the text gets
so complex, they can't
handle that, right?
And so, as we look at that,
the other things, so they have
that trouble with the
phonological component
of the language, taking in those
sounds, putting those sounds
to those symbols, but also, you
know, their spelling will be
where you'll really,
really see it.
Spanish speakers, you know,
the language is transparent
and so you'll see that,
you know what, they're able
to come along, it seems
like their decoding is OK,
and where you'll find it is they
won't be very fluent readers
and their spelling will
very clearly suffer.
And so, what are the
secondary things that we see?
Well, if I don't have access to
be able and the ability to be--
you know, I need access
that you talk about.
But now I can't read what's
in front of me and I want
so desperately to be able
to do this and I'm smarter
than this other kid that can
do it right next to me, right?
And so what do we see
as secondary problems?
Well, then you don't read.
And because you don't
read, what will suffer?
Your vocabulary will
suffer, you know.
Your reading, you're
not going to read--
if you can't read
accurately or fluently,
eventually your reading
and comprehension is going
to suffer, and then certainly
your written language.
But the other thing is,
what are some early signs?
And so-- I'm a speech and
language pathologist and so
as I look at children,
when we see these children
with these speech disorders
called phonological processing
disorders, and we're trying to
really do the studies right now
to really predict which ones
of these phonological processing
disorders will have dyslexia
and which ones won't.
So that means these children--
have you ever seen children
that when they speak to you,
they're really little
toddlers, go-go-ga-ga.
You don't understand
anything that they're saying.
Well, we figure out in their
speech and language world
that they have a phonological
processing disorder and we can,
you know, really remediate that.
We work with them intensely.
But we follow those children
very carefully because many
of them may also
have this disability
that we know of as dyslexia.
And the other thing is, you
know, dyslexia, this is a myth
that it's a visual disorder.
People think it's seeing things
backwards or mirror reading.
In fact, you know, why
would they do that?
Well, it's about disability
to sequence and the ability
for directionality, knowing,
you know, that you do this first
and next and left, my
right side, my left side.
Some of us-- Actually
they've seen
that some us women have
trouble with that too, right?
But I know to ask
for directions.
And the other thing is the
early things of just, you know,
when we play with language,
you know, you all talk
about Dr. Seuss books.
You know, rhyming,
rhyming is so important.
And these are things
that we've not only found
out about the English
language, the Spanish language,
alphabetic languages,
but we've also seen it
in non-alphabetic languages
that how important this is.
So this center-- this reading
center of the brain that we see
in this left temporal lobe
is also your language center.
And so I heard earlier
today mentioned about--
you mentioned about listening
and speaking and reading
and writing and being
a storyteller.
But, you know, literacy
really, you know, we have--
we must have these
opportunities for language
to have ultimate
goal of literacy,
and that ultimate goal is that
deep understanding of text
and the enjoyment and
the ability to be engaged
and motivated about it.
And so, because of these issues,
we start to feel really bad
about ourselves if you
have these disabilities.
And what will end up
happening for these students,
if they don't have an expert
teacher that can help them
and work through
these, what will end
up happening is we
see high levels--
you know, the National
Institute of Child Health
and Human Development
sponsors our research.
And they sponsor it because we
want to prevent these issues
of reading disabilities but
also mental health disabilities.
Because these individuals become
very anxious and depressed
about there inability to
read, and when they know,
I am just as smart as any-- this
person and anybody in this room.
And so, we see these issues,
issues also related
to attention.
About 40% of our dyslexic
students will also have issues
with attention, and so we
want to really get this early
and remediate it early.
And so, our mission now is--
and I've had the opportunity to,
you know, really
understand about this.
And through the National
Institute of Child Health
and Human Development
grants and the Institute
of Education Sciences at the
Department of Ed, we've been--
you know, our research has
been funded and we've been able
to look at these English
learners and we've been able
to look at these children
with issues such as dyslexia,
and we've been able to
look across languages
and see what's going
on across languages.
And finally, understanding
how beautiful it is
to be biliterate, to be--
you know, to be able to
read across languages.
But to know that
having that ability
in one language will help
you in that second language.
And so, we are looking now at
making sure that all children--
so, our initiatives
now are to look
in the general education
classrooms in these early years
to make sure that children have
access to beautiful language,
to understanding
how languages work,
to understanding those
sound system, the phonology,
understanding the morphology,
those words and word parts.
Sixty percent of the English
language comes from Latin.
And these, you know,
Latin and Greek roots
which we call morphemes,
those are so important for us,
for learning the vocabulary,
the second language.
But also understanding
how it works and puts--
how we put language
together for sentences,
how sentences make paragraphs,
and how we're able to read.
And so, just really looking at
that ability to get to what?
What is our goal?
To have a wonderful
comprehension
and comprehension skills, but
first we have to make sure
that they also have those
early literacy skills
of being able to read.
So, the--
>> Laura Bailet: Elsa.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: Yeah.
>> Laura Bailet: You know,
I'm going to be mindful
of time then maybe give
Lydia a chance to--
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: Yes.
So, here's my-- yeah.
Just here is my last slide.
So the last slide here just
shows, we want deep levels
of comprehension and expression
and lifelong reading
and writing habits.
And we can start early and
we can work with our teachers
in the general education
classrooms to really achieve
and we won't stop until
everyone can read.
Thank you [applause].
>> Laura Bailet: It
will circle back to you.
And now, we have Dr. Lydia
Carlis and she's going
to talk a little bit more
about the literacy challenges
of persons with-- of color.
And you can sit or you can stand
however you want to do that.
And then, we're going to
talk a little bit more
about some solutions
and technology.
>> Lydia Carlis: So,
I'm-- I am Lydia Carlis.
And I am going to not talk
generally about people of color
but specifically
about black children.
And just say that a lot of
the same issues and concerns
that Elsa just shared are
also issues and concerns
for African-American
children learning English,
learning this-- the language
of instruction and the language
of business in schools.
So, if African-American children
speak African-American English
at home and they do not
learn how to code-switch,
then they will be-- have
trouble reading later,
they will have trouble
learning to read early.
One of the statistics that I
read in my doctoral program
that really solidified it for
me that I was going to work
in early childhood was that
67% of children, who struggle
to read in kindergarten,
continue to struggle
to read in third grade.
And so, while we have a country
that does not have
universal preschool,
that often does not
have mandatory
or full-day kindergarten, we
know that there are so much
that we can be doing
for children
who struggle the most early,
and we should be doing that.
And that is especially
important for children who need
to learn both the language
of instruction and continue
to value the language
that they speak at home,
the dialect that
they speak at home.
So, a lot-- there's
research coming out now
that bidialectism is just as
been official as bilingualism.
So, for your brain--
children who can do
that code-switching
do have efficiency
in both languages
is very important.
So, this is something
to value and celebrate
with African-American
children and not to talk
about proper English
versus improper English,
but talk about language of
school, language of instruction
and your home language,
your home--
like what you speak at
home is just as valuable.
But we want to give
you opportunities
and that's the same way that
we look at it with children
who come to us speaking Spanish.
But we don't always tell
African-American parents,
please talk to your child
in your home dialect.
I've never heard
teachers say that.
But we will now, we
know what to say.
Please read to your child
now in your home language
or whichever language is
most comfortable for you.
So those are the kinds of
things that we should be saying
to families of African-American
children as well.
And I think I'll stop there.
>> Laura Bailet: Yeah, I
think I've read some research
where that code-switching
either between a dialect
and a more formal version
of a language or between two
or more actual different
languages really fosters working
memory and it also
improves executive function
because you're having
to really attend
to multiple cues simultaneously
and instantaneously decide,
I need to speak in this
language right now.
I remember when I was working
in the clinic years ago,
I ran a neurocognitive
assessment program
in the neurology division--
Child Neurology Division
in a clinic in Florida
and I had a little four-year-old
who was referred to me
for question of language
disorder.
He came from a Spanish-speaking
home and his English was behind.
But I had an intern
working with me who was
from Colombia, South America.
And she only spoke to him
in English but clearly
with a Spanish accent.
I obviously don't
have a Spanish accent.
And this child instantaneously
would speak Spanish to my intern
and speak English to me and I
said, OK, we're going to find
out what your child's
strengths are
and if there are any weaknesses,
but he doesn't have
a language disorder
because he is sorting it
out very, very quickly.
And that's that code-switching
that is really great
for executive function
and frontal lobe function.
And now there's research
actually showing
that being bilingual or
trilingual is protective
of Alzheimer's in later life.
So bad for those of us who
are monolingual but, you know,
we'll have to do
the best we can.
So I would love for each
of you to share things
that you're doing in your
program or other programs
that you're aware of
that are solutions.
Elsa, I know you were--
you're getting right--
you were getting right to
talk more before I kind
of cut you off to give Lydia
a chance but to talk about--
we do know how to teach
struggling readers to read.
I mean, it's not necessarily
easy for all of them,
but we know what to do and
there are many examples
where this is working.
And it's interesting today there
hasn't been much discussion
about the use of technology
for struggling readers
even though many of us--
even though we're good readers,
also avail ourselves
of audio books.
So I want to also spend some
time talking about technology.
So I don't know who wants
to go first, I can't choose.
It's like choosing
my favorite child,
you know, I can't do that.
So one of you jump in
there to share an example
of something you know that's
working well or some technology.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
Well, one of the things we--
I mean, there's so
much available now
and a lot of it is for free.
And so for children with
disabilities, I mean, we--
you know, some of them have, you
know, they don't want to write,
they don't want to read.
So some of the things
we do as we get them
into that reading is, you know,
we would use your services
that you have for
the audio books.
We use Learning Ally.
But the other thing is like
just to get them even to want
to also tell their stories
and write, we use things
like Dragon Speak,
which is, you know,
something that they
can just, you know,
download and get for free.
They can just, you know,
And then they love that.
They see-- seen what they've
said in print and that gets them
to be more encouraged
about that.
>> Kristen Fernekes: You had
asked a question about e-braille
and I did want to just
follow up about that.
E-braille is amazing to me.
It's-- So, again, we have
printed braille materials
available to our patrons.
We also distribute our books
and what is-- it's a format BRF.
So, these files can be
downloaded and then imported
to a digital braille reader,
which is a amazing machine
that basically just sort of--
to I've described as a ticker.
The pins come up to
represent the braille words,
which is something
that we're moving--
not only are we moving toward
more books in e-braille,
we are also working to try
and produce a more
affordable e-braille machine.
So, they're wonderful machines.
They're little bit fragile
because you can imagine
you've got pins were popping
up all the time.
And they're also
non-inexpensive.
So, it's such a quick way to
be able to distribute books
and other materials to
people, so it's something
that NLS is really pursuing.
And my director just
went to a huge conference
out in California, where
people coming from all
over the world looking for
ways to create this technology
in a way that is really going
to be more accessible to people.
Because, you know, if you--
there's something very--
in speaking to my colleagues
who use braille all the time,
I think there's something
about taking that information
in that way that
it's very familiar
and it's something that-- for
anybody who feels, you know,
this deep love of reading
books, there's also this type
of component of it to it.
>> Laura Bailet: Right.
>> Kristen Fernekes: So
we do want to mention
that we can achieve
that and make it
as successful as possible.
It's amazing technology.
We're hoping to get it out--
>> Laura Bailet: Wow.
>> Kristen Fernekes:
-- to more people.
>> Lydia Carlis: And I was
just on a plane this morning,
I wasn't supposed to be
but I was, and before I got
on the plane from the hotel
to the airport there was a mom
from a small town in
Alabama and she's talking
about her first grade reader
who was struggling with reading
and not getting all the help
she wanted from the teacher.
So one of-- Two resources that I
gave her were, one was Raz-Kids,
reading A to Z. But the Raz-Kids
portion of it is online,
allows the children to
read but also to read
into the book and it records it.
So, when I was a teacher a long
time ago, that was very helpful
for me because I
could go back later
and actually analyze
the children's reading,
whereas I wouldn't have time
to do that with every child
in the room right
at that moment.
So I gave her that resource
and then the kids were also just
more motivated because it was
on a computer and it
was pretty and animated.
And then a newer resource is
called Beanstack and it is
like a Fitbit for books.
And so, you know, I'm around
babies now and toddlers
and preschoolers, and babies
know how to swipe, right?
They are using technology
more and more early
in their-- early in life.
And so, the ability for
them to get badges and see
where they're following
is motivating for kids.
So, that's another resource.
They could-- It's
really used now a lot
in summer reading programs.
So that's a cool thing
that you can suggest
to families and teachers.
And I want to say
one more thing.
Oh, and the other thing
is ensuring that you have
as many culturally
relevant books as possible
from the earliest age.
So-- And not just--
There are a lot of books
for African-American students
children now, or not a lot,
but there are some books
there but many of them focus
on I love my hair or
things that are important,
but are not getting
into academics
and I can be a chemist,
I can be--
you know, I have an ability to
see myself as an academic, as--
whatever it is that
they want to do.
And that is super
important that we continue
to create more culturally
relevant books
that reflect the children doing
things that are aspirational.
So just trying to make
sure that you find those
for kids as young as possible.
>> Laura Bailet: And Lydia,
I think you mentioned to me
that you've worked with
First Book on that topic
and First Book was one
of the award winner--
Rubenstein Award
winners for the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards
Program a couple of years ago.
So, can you--
>> Lydia Carlis: Sure.
>> Laura Bailet: -- comment
a little bit on that?
This is a topic that the
Literacy Awards Board has
discussed fairly regularly,
is the issue of diversity in--
>> Lydia Carlis: Yes.
>> Laura Bailet: -- books
for children and adults.
And I know all the
publishers are focusing on that
but I'd love to hear more
about what you're
doing with First Book.
>> Lydia Carlis: So, I
am a fan of First Book.
I have not have actually
worked with First Book.
But First Book, what I loved
about what they're doing is
that they have a whole-- I
won't even say as a section,
they have an initiative ensure
that books that are written
by people with color, that
reflect people of color,
are prominently shared with
schools, with organizations
that needs to get books.
And so that is super
exciting for me because I want
to see the kids represented in
the books that they are reading.
And when I was at
AppleTree Institute,
one of our initiatives
was to write books.
We wrote over a 120
books while I was there.
Sixty-six percent of them
feature children of color.
And the reason that-- or
people of color, and the reason
that we did that was because
when we went and spent weeks,
I sent the writers and
had them spend weeks
in the library areas, we
could not find many books
that we're talking about physics
and astronomy or archeology
and paleontology, or earth
science that had people
of color dominate in
what was happening,
but our schools were 97, you
know, 95% African-American
and there was no one that was--
that looked like
them represented.
So, we were able to do that work
for the curriculum
that we were writing.
And so now when I see more
organizations that are doing
that more broadly and then
trying to curate and make sure
that everyone has access
to books like that,
it just does my heart good.
>> Laura Bailet: So for those
of you who are mindful of time,
God gave me permission
to go a little bit longer
so I'm going to take it.
So, we have a few more minutes.
And I did want to point out to
you the last couple of slides
that we-- that my panel
collectively created.
This is not an exhaustive
list of technology resources
but it's a good sampling of
some of the technology resources
that are available
or websites that talk
about resources that
are available.
So, Reading Rockets is on there.
So I have two slides because
there are so many things now.
Audible.com is the
Amazon one writes.
So that one you have to pay for.
I was on that website very
briefly this past week
in preparation for the panel
and they actually had a quote
on there, it said,
"Listening is the new reading."
So, remember that because
I want to circle back.
I want to canvass this
group and see what you think
about that, but it's
interesting.
And then Lydia mentioned
Beanstack, Bookshare,
Colorin Colorado, Dyslexia
Yale, IDA's new website,
and I'm coming back
to you, Elsa.
I have a question for you.
Headstrong Nation is a
really interesting website
that was created by Ben Foss,
who's an absolutely brilliant
guy with very severe dyslexia
and ADHD by his own admission.
And he-- on his website
teaches struggling readers how
to access audible text.
And so I was on his
website and I hate to admit
that I did not know this.
But on every Microsoft computer
now that is reasonably recent
and on every reasonably
recent Apple computer,
it is already built it.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: Yeah.
>> Laura Bailet: You can get--
You can get audible on
everything that's on there.
Everything-- Whatever page
you're on, you just right click
and then it says read aloud, and
it just reads it aloud to you.
It's amazing.
So, there's incredible resources
for people who either struggle
to read or for whatever
reason, they prefer to listen
to something because
they're driving
or because it's just easier for
them to process information.
So that's already available
on tablets and on computers.
And then there are-- I put the--
your website, the loc.gov/nls.
Learningally.org has-- I can't
remember how many hundreds
of thousands of book titles.
You do have to pay
for that service.
A lot of school systems
purchased that service
so that the child or the
family doesn't have to pay,
but you can order any book
and it is actually read
by human being which
is very, very nice.
The computer-generated speech
is getting much, much better
but it's still
computer-generated.
But these are actually
read by live people
so you get the vocal inflection
and that kind of thing.
And so, anyway, this is some
representative websites.
But I would love to ask Elsa and
hear from others on my panel,
what is the International
Dyslexia Association approach
right now with people with
dyslexia specially children?
How early should we introduce
audio books and, you know,
make these tools available to
them versus continuing to try
and help them and prioritize
them actually becoming readers?
I think that's a
really huge issue.
I'd love to hear your
perspective on that.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: So yeah.
So, well, the huge initiative
we have right now is making sure
our teachers are well-equipped
to teach all kids
including children
with disabilities
such as dyslexia.
And we can prevent many
of them ever getting
to special education when we
do that before the third grade.
I mean, we know that.
And then when we don't identify
them before the third grade
and we look at them at ninth
grade, we look at them at--
there's-- they still remain--
67% of them will remain
well below, you know,
that expected reading level.
So we're really focused
on, you know, more--
you know, working
on the prevention
as well as the intervention.
But you-- [inaudible].
What was that?
So-- And by third, when we
look at them in third grade
and we look at them
and we look--
if we identify them in third
grade then we follow them
to ninth grade, then
we're still seeing
that they're still below
their average reading level
in the ninth grade.
>> They're below grade level.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
Yes, below grade level.
>> And 50% of kids are
below grade level anyway.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: Yeah.
Yeah. You know, we
need to do a better--
yeah, we have children
that aren't-- that's right.
And especially when we look at
the English learners and we look
at our African-American
population,
if you look at the
NAEP scores, yes.
But what we want to look at
in regards to that, you know,
there's always the question
about when do we introduce all
these extra accommodations,
right?
>> Laura Bailet: Right.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
Because then--
you know, then you're like, oh
well, why should I have to read
when I have all this
ability to gain the access.
And then you're right
about young children.
They're already, you know,
and as infants already--
you see them already doing-- and
they have no fear of technology
like us old people do.
And so, you know, so,
number one, we always want
to teach them to read but we do
also want them to have access
and why can't you, you know,
do the both at the same time.
>> Lydia Carlis: And I just say
for all kids, but especially
for kids who are struggling
to read or to learn in school,
teaching them
about metacognition is super
important from preschool.
So teaching them to understand
how they learn best is
really important.
Yeah.
>> Laura Bailet: So I'd like
to open it up now to questions
or comments from everyone in
the audience and also questions
for the panel that went ahead
of us, creating, developing
and sustaining lifelong readers.
So, what do you guys think or
what questions do you have?
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: None.
>> Lydia Carlis:
We answered it all.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
Can we ask a question?
>> So I just have-- I'm just
kind of curious about folks
that have dyslexia in
different orthographic system.
So how does that play out?
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
That's right.
So, when we look across
languages, even languages
that are non-alphabetic,
as I mentioned we do see
that they still will have
difficulty in this issue,
the phonological
component of the language.
When we look at languages that
are more transparent such as
like Italian and Spanish,
we see that, oh, you know,
because of that transparency
and the regularity,
they seem to be able to get
at that decoding
OK, not so, so bad.
But what they won't
have is the fluency
and then the orthography,
the spelling and writing.
>> Laura Bailet: There has been
a crosslinguistic research quite
a bit and dyslexia has been
found in virtually every--
in every written language, so.
But the exact format and the
brain processing patterns
associated with it will differ
according to the structure,
the linguistic structure
of the language.
So it's really fascinating.
I mean, the-- You know, the
short answer is, as I said,
learning to read is a
challenging task for the brain.
I've heard one where a
scientist say, you know,
dyslexia wasn't a problem
until Gutenberg invented the
printing press in the 1400s
and the masses were suddenly
expected to become readers.
I mean, before then, you
know, it was a select few
who were readers and writers--
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: Yeah.
>> Laura Bailet: --
and everybody else,
you know, was all oral.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: Yeah.
>> Laura Bailet: So all of a
sudden, we created a new class
of disability with
the printing press.
It's a very challenging
late-emerging skill
in the course of
human development.
So it is challenging that
having said that we do know how
to teach most, if not
all children to read.
And it is never too late
to teach someone to read,
but you get far better outcomes
if you take an earlier
preventive approach.
So, was there a question--
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: So
I just have something more--
>> Laura Bailet: OK.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
-- to mention about that.
So in our-- our studies
are mainly
with Spanish-speaking English
learners that have disabilities
and then looking at those
components and looking
across languages and
across linguistic features.
And we find that, for example,
if they have those capabilities
in their language, then
they're going to be
on a great journey
towards literacy
in their second language.
And that if they didn't
have those abilities,
then certainly it affects
their first language,
it's going to certainly
affect their second language.
>> Lydia Carlis: Benita,
do you have a question?
>> Benita Somerfield: A lot
of materials [inaudible]
disabilities.
I mean, as you know,
as we've all said,
the content of what people
read has a tremendous effect
on motivation and
everything else.
And as you mentioned, the
psychological damage to somebody
with the child has
reading difficulties,
learning difficulties only
increases as you go older.
I've seen people say,
well, it's the same skills
so we give them children's
materials--
>> Laura Bailet: Right.
>> Benita Somerfield:
That flies in the face
of everything else that we know.
Is there anything that
you would recommend
that you've seen that's
specifically designed
for adults?
>> Laura Bailet: To
teach them reading
but that's developmentally
appropriate teaching materials.
>> Benita Somerfield:
Exactly, exactly.
>> Laura Bailet: I think
that is a huge problem.
And as much as there
are similarities
in how children learn to read
and adults learn to read,
they're very, very different.
I really know what dyslexia
is, first and foremost,
because I had to teach a
37-year-old dyslexic man
to read.
And I had previously been
trying to teach kindergarten
through eight graders to read.
And they-- But they weren't able
to tell me what they
were getting
and what they weren't getting.
He was a really bright guy
who had great self-awareness
and insight.
He could tell me exactly
what parts made sense to him
and exactly what didn't
make sense to him.
And I feel like with
adult learners,
we often don't take advantage
of the learning capabilities
that they have that you
simply don't have at age six.
But I don't know if you can
comment on specific programs.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Laura Bailet: Oh absolutely.
>> Benita Somerfield:
Employees and everybody else.
So their mental skills
extremely strong, quite bright.
So not drawing on--
that's the major piece,
not drawing on their
background information,
not drawing on the
skills they've developed.
They're pretending they are
the same as children by going
through a skills-based approach
I think is, from my experience,
is just a major mistake.
>> Lydia Carlis: This is not
specific to adult with dyslexia
but one of the amazing
interventions I saw
at a Heard Start program
is that their approach
to family literacy and how they
are teaching adult literacy is
by using the child's
report card,
by using the things they
go home, the newsletters
so that they are
doing-- using something,
materials that are important
to the parent and meaningful
and they are going about that
in a way that it's systematic
and supportive and helps
them get throughout the year
and understanding they have
to be great advocates
for their kids.
>> Laura Bailet:
That gets back to,
in a couple of the
earlier panels,
the theme of relevance has kept
coming up, that the materials--
you don't have to
have everything.
It doesn't have to be
completely comprehensive.
But whether you do have, it'd
better be relevant and it needs
to be relevant like right
now because now they're going
to read that report
card or that newsletter
and they need to
respond right now.
>> Lydia Carlis: Yeah.
>> Laura Bailet: Two weeks
from now they've
missed that opportunity.
>> Lydia Carlis: Yeah.
>> Laura Bailet: So
that just in time kind
of relevance is important.
Elsa, were you or--
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan: Yeah.
And I just think that that's
exactly what I was going to say.
So you have to-- So when
you work with the adults,
it has to be the things
that they want to read,
what's relevant to them and
let's help you to figure out,
you know, how to get through
that and understand it well.
And so that's-- yeah,
you don't treat them
like you would a little kid.
Absolutely not.
>> Laura Bailet: I can
share another quick story
of my adult with dyslexia.
So two things brought
him in to our clinic
at Northwestern University.
One was he want to be able
to read to his children,
which he'd never done before.
And number two, he
was so capable
in his job at Glidden Paints.
He was running all of their
very complicated equipment
and machinery and he was
so good at it and this was
in the late '70s, early '80s
when the EPA said, you know,
we've got to stop, our
paint manufacturers have
to stop polluting.
And so, all the paint
manufacturers were going to have
to spend millions and million
and millions of dollars
on really expensive
anti-pollution equipment.
So his boss had given him these
huge detailed manuals and said,
Mel, I need you to read
this and tell us which piece
of equipment we should buy.
Well, you can imagine
his terror at that.
He would take everything
home and his wife,
who spoke like eight languages,
would read it aloud to him
and he would memorize it,
that memory capability,
so that he could go back
the next day and fake
that he was reading it and
spelling off what it said.
So those were the things
that brought him in,
but what he really wanted to
do was open his own heating
and refrigeration company.
So I had to get him
through an 895-page textbook
on heating and refrigeration.
So that was quite a scene as
you can imagine for two years.
I could never get him to see and
hear pattens and rhyming words
like hat, mat, fat, cat, sat.
But one day, one Tuesday night,
he brought the book into me
and he was so excited to show me
he had highlighted all the words
in this heating and
refrigeration book that ended
in U-R-E, pressure,
moisture, temperature.
And for the first time,
the concept of patterns
in words made sense to him.
What I have ever thought
to show those words to him
when he couldn't read, no,
but that's what I'm saying.
They will tell you
what they need
and what will work for them.
You have to partner with them
and you have to ask them,
what are you motivated
to read about?
So he got his heating and
refrigeration program.
Yup.
>> I was going to say what
Ms. Benita was saying.
It goes back to what
Joshua and Lois spoke
about earlier as far as empathy.
And those people who are
teaching adult literacy have
to maintain empathy
and non-judgments
when they are teaching
them so that they do have--
they do feel more
liberated to choose,
and also feel more liberated to
choose what is relevant to them
in order to learn to read and
knock out adult illiteracy.
In that way, you can better
knock out childhood illiteracy.
>> Laura Bailet: Absolutely.
Thank you so much.
Thank you to my wonderful panel.
>> Elsa Cardenas-Hagan:
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Guy Lamolinara:
Thank you very much.
>> Laura Bailet: OK, good.
>> Guy Lamolinara:
Thank you again
for another great discussion
and we'll break until 3 o'clock
and then we'll have
our last panel.
Thanks. OK.
Thanks again for staying
around for our last program
and I think it's going
to be well worthwhile
because it's a topic that really
has woven itself throughout all
the discussions today.
And that's the important
topic of diversity in books,
the current state
and the future.
And we could not have a better
moderator for this panel
than Ellen Oh, who is the--
an author and she is a CEO
and President of "We
Need Diverse Books."
So please welcome Ellen Oh.
[ Applause ]
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, do
I have to get up or?
>> Meg Medina: Sure.
>> Ellen Oh: Can I stay seated?
>> Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: All right, good.
Oh, that's good for my back.
Hi everyone.
I am so thrilled to be here
because I'm on panel with two
of my favorite people.
And we know each other
because we all work with--
for We Need Diverse
Books together.
And it's been four years,
four momentous years,
lots of change has happened.
Let me show a little bio first
because I actually took
the time to do these.
First, we'll start
with Meg Medina.
Meg, talk a little
bit about yourself.
>> Meg Medina: Oh.
So I'm Meg and those
are some of my title.
I am very proud to
be a founding member
of We Need Diverse
Books with Ellen.
I'm also very proud to do
a lot of program in here
at the Library of Congress, and
as it happens a lot of research
on my books here at the
Library of Congress.
For "Burn Baby Burn," I was here
for hours and hours and hours.
And I spent the morning
doing the same thing today.
So I'm very happy
to be here today.
>> Ellen Oh: And Meg's books
are amazing and I'm sure all
of you have read
all of them, right?
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah, yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Just say yes.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
>> Ellen Oh: OK.
So, Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich--
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yes.
>> Ellen Oh: -- and
her wonderful books is,
like I have to say
"Eight-Grade Superzero."
I love this book.
The "Burn Baby Burn,"
I love this--
these are like two of my
favorite books in the world.
So imagine how I
feel sitting here,
sitting with my two favorite
authors of great books.
So please tell a little
bit about yourself.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Well,
you said just about all
that needs to be said.
>> Ellen Oh: New book, new book.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
So I'm Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich
and I'm the author of
"Eight-Grade Superzero"
and the co-author
of "Two Naomis"
and forthcoming "Naomis Too."
And then also this
fall, "Someday Is Now,"
the story Clara Luper
and the 1958 sit-ins.
And "Above and Beyond:
NASA's Journey to Tomorrow"
which was a lot of fun to work
on in a rush because it was just
so different and it was an
opportunity for me to find a lot
of hidden his stories and her
stories that were involved
in NASA's work over the year.
So that was incredible.
Before I was an author
for a very long time,
starting as a college
freshman, I worked in literacy,
family literacy and
youth development
and that informs a lot
of the work I do now with
"We Need Diverse Books."
>> Ellen Oh: Oh,
we have to go back
for one little second
because, Meg,
what is the new book
coming up this year?
>> Meg Medina: Oh it's
"Merci Suarez Changes Gears"
which comes out in 2018
and began as a short story
in our anthology, which I
think cycles back to your work.
Ellen, now you're
in the hot seat.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yes.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
So, I'm Ellen Oh.
And the book she's talking about
is "Flying Lessons" which is
on the slide which is
the short story anthology
that WNDB put together.
And it has been a remarkable
experience being able to take
that book all over the
country to students and kind
of let them know that there--
this is a book of
stories for everybody.
But let me talk also about
WNDB, because I think
that since 2014,
a lot has changed.
What do you think guys?
Yeah. And I think my-- some
of my proudest moments I think
for all of us, some
of our proudest moments
is seeing the actual work
become reality.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: So, Bem, if
you don't mind, can you talk
about the internship program?
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Sure.
The Internship Grant Award
Program, we award grants
of usually $2500 to applicants
from underrepresented
backgrounds to get internships
in the public-- children's
publishing industry.
So they could be with
publishing companies,
with literary agencies, and they
may not always be editorial.
We've had some interns who
were in marketing and publicity
and art direction which
is great to sort of have
that diversity in
their experiences.
And in addition to the grant,
we-- throughout the summer,
we offer them opportunities
to meet
with publishing professionals.
And to me, with-- like I
took them on a trip to,
I'm like intern mom
in the summer,
so to meet with book sellers,
to meet with people who work
in lots of different
areas of the industry
so that they can see not
just where they work but some
of the different opportunities
that they can have.
And we've had out
of 25 WNDB interns,
I think 14 have already gone
on to get full-time jobs
in children's publishing
or in publishing.
And a lot of the rest
are still in school
because you can be either a
student or recent graduate.
So we've just been
really proud of them.
>> Ellen Oh: I get to highlight
the fact that my editors,
assistant is actually
WNDB intern.
So that's been an amazing
feeling to be working
with somebody who
started off as an intern.
The other thing I
wanted to mention is
that the reason why the
internship program is
so important is because
statistically,
publishing has been 90% white.
And what that translates into
is less books about, you know,
people of color and other
marginalized communities,
and also a lack of understanding
of what these communities
are going through
and what a book would look like
if it's going to be authentic.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: And one thing
that was important to
us with the giving--
with giving a grant was
that when people get
these internships,
even if they are paid,
they're not paid very much.
And to live in New--
to live and work
in New York City is expensive.
So, that was a big
barrier to a lot of people
from marginalized backgrounds
to just being a part
of the industry.
>> Ellen Oh: Exactly.
So now, we'll also get to talk
about grants and mentorships
and the Walter Award and
WNDB in the classroom.
And, you know, we
have a lot of programs
and they're doing great.
We have these wonderful success
stories that we can point to.
For example, Angie Thomas was
our inaugural WNDB grant winner.
And look what-- like
she is on fire.
So, we have all these
programs and the idea is
to really give opportunities
to writers
who just have not had them
before, and also to promote
and market books in ways that
they have not received before,
because how can you know
about or see or read a book
if you've never heard about it,
right, which kind of takes me
to next issue which
is the changing face
of the New York Times
bestseller list.
So, what do you think Meg?
>> Meg Medina: So, I
think a couple things.
The first thing that comes
to mind as I'm listening
to our sort of detail what's
been happening on our end
over the past few years, a
couple of things to know.
First is that if you
look around this room,
everybody in here is pretty
much like minded in terms
of feeling the importance of
books that represent all kids,
windows, mirrors, that
entire conversation.
But we are well past
that conversation now.
We don't want to-- You know,
we're all in agreement.
Yes, yes, and now what?
So, this is sort of
like 2.0 at this point.
What is the next series of
thing that we need to look at?
And what I'm so proud of that
We Need Diverse Books has done
with the-- with its partners
and with a very small
volunteer group of people,
is create action that
really has the greatest cope
of changing who's at the
table making decisions,
making conversation around
the books we're choosing,
and how we market them.
So when I look at this list
also, I can't help but think
of what the list looked like
four, five years earlier, right?
So, this is the New York
Times bestseller list
from April, is it not?
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: Right.
And so, do we have a
graphic of the one from 2012
or we were not able to--
>> Ellen Oh: We were unable to.
>> Meg Medina: At that one,
there was one author who I'm
so proud to say is a good friend
of mine, but Wonder was still
on the New York Times
bestseller list six years ago.
People, that's a long run.
And Raquel-- R. J.
Palacio is Colombian.
So, we had that.
But everybody else was a
white author on that list.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
And mostly male.
>> Meg Medina: And mostly male.
And so, it's amazing
to see the change.
And it's not only
WNDB, obviously.
There are many, many
warriors on the ground,
who are pushing this
ball forward.
But that's the thing
that makes my heart sing.
And so-- And addresses--
I don't know how you felt
when you started.
But when I first started,
like this myth or this worry
that we were going
to be niche authors,
that we were only
speaking to our-- a small--
like I could only be speaking
to let you know, like readers,
right, and that our books
wouldn't sell widely.
Goodbye to that idea.
>> Ellen Oh: Exactly.
We're destroying myths.
You know, this myth-- this
idea that publishing had
such a long time that
black books didn't sell,
that books about Latinos or
Asians that they didn't sell.
And we have destroyed that myth
because of all those red
circles on that list.
So, it's an amazing
feeling to see that change.
And what we have to do
is to keep that going.
And like Meg said,
it's not just WNDB.
It's all-- It's everybody.
It's all of you.
It's the librarians and the
teachers and the parents
and booksellers and
everybody who cares.
And that brings me to
the role of gatekeepers
in children's literature,
because in general,
we are talking about us as
gatekeepers who kind of all
on the same page, right?
That's what makes it-- If we're
here, we're probably all here.
But we have to kind of take
this message more globally
and make all people realize
how important it is to talk
about like teaching empathy
to children from a young age,
which I think if we take
the next slide-- no.
OK. I'm skipping slides, sorry.
I wanted to go to this slide.
>> Meg Medina: OK.
>> Ellen Oh: Because
this was 2012, right?
If we're talking about a
New York Times book list
from that time period,
this is what the statistics
for the books looked like.
Out of 3600 books
published in that year,
7% were about a child of color.
And if we don't talk
to gatekeepers
about why diversity is so
important, we're never going
to change what's happening.
We're always only
going to be talking
to the same like-minded
people, right?
We've got to kind of
get thee on that base
so that we don't
have to go back.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
And I think it has
a lot to do with--
for ourselves, we should
start asking that question,
as a writing assignment that's
given a lot, where I'm from
or asking where am I from.
So as gatekeepers asking
ourselves, even asking people
who already feel like
we're doing pretty well
or like we got this, where am
I from and what does that mean
about the books that
I recommend,
about how I share literature,
how I talk about literature,
how I see the population
that I serve,
am I sort of using
a deficit model.
You can unconsciously-- What
are the implicit biases I have
and asking ourselves those
hard questions and figuring
out what we're going to do about
them on a very personal level.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: Well, I'll tell
you one thing that changed
for me in this whole process.
So, I was a teacher
before I was an author.
It was a job I loved.
And of course, I loved--
the role of children's books
in my classroom was
really, really large.
As a teacher, I remember doing
this and certainly as an author.
You know, and I was just talking
about this a few minutes ago
because I have this book
coming out in September
and you're waiting for
the reviews, right?
And so, what are the
reviews you're thinking of?
You're thinking of Kirkus, ah,
right, that's the scariest one
of all, right, Kirkus review.
And then SLJ and like all of
the major reviewing places.
So the interesting thing
is that I have started
to ask myself harder questions
about that relationship also
because the truth is that those
reviewing agencies are also
struggling with biases that
they're just now uncovering,
and a lack of-- not a lack of,
but a very few number of people
of color writing the reviews.
And so, you don't know
what you don't know, right?
You fall into these mistakes
or statements or lack of tuning
into something really
important in the book
because it's not part
of your experience.
So, one thing that's really
changed for me is that sure,
I go to Kirkus and SLJ
and so on and I'm picking
out what they say
about my book and books
that I'm interested in, but I
also make a stop at the blogs
and so on of librarians
of color, of academics
and I am trying to listen
to what the conversation is
and to pick up on my own biases.
And we were talking about
this at lunch that, you know,
even with authors
of color and people
from diverse backgrounds,
we have biases too.
And it's so-- Like you have
to just ask yourself
hard questions,
which is I think
what we were talking
about in terms of
this work at 2.0.
It's now getting to the
really uncomfortable parts
where you have to look
at things you used to do,
opinions you've had,
and how you've changed
and really owning them.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: I think it's also
important that we also talk
about do we change, how we talk
about books in a way that like
for example, for
me, I was always
like representation is
important, you know,
representation is
empowering, that's all great.
And yes, absolutely,
very important.
But empathy is really important.
And part of that process is
making sure white kids read
about black kids, black
kids read about Latino kids,
Latino kids read
about Asian kids,
Asian kids read about disabled.
You see the circle?
We have to actually be
completely open and learn
from each other,
become empathetic.
Empathy is not, you know,
something we're born with.
Empathy is what we learn.
If you don't know that
somebody from your--
you know, from a different
community or background
because you've never had any
experience with that, you know,
community, where are
you going to turn to?
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
And I think that comes in I
think of how sometimes even
when we mean well and mean to be
inclusive, we end up otherizing.
And it reminds me one experience
I had as a middle schooler.
After having been a kid
who moved around a lot
to all these different
schools and different countries
and being this new kid
like over and over,
I came to this one school
in suburban New York
where the teacher
meant to be welcoming.
And my first day, when I
really just wanted to like stay
under the radar, kind of
get the feel of the place
and then be cool and fit in and
like, I don't know, be president
or whatever I had in my head.
I had just moved
from Lagos, Nigeria.
We had lived in Lagos,
Nigeria for a year
and then come to New York.
So, the teacher was like, oh,
we have a new student who's
just come to us from Africa.
Come up to the front of the room
and tell us all about Africa.
So, that was a problem for
a lot of different reasons.
But the one thing that she did
was, in trying to, I think,
include me and welcome me,
she really otherized me.
And in middle school,
that's really like not cool.
>> Ellen Oh: It's
where are you from?
No, no, no, where
are you really from?
And I now say my mother's
uterus, because like
that is actually where
we're really from, you know.
No, but seriously, the whole
point is that like this idea
of like making feel--
making people feel like they're
not real Americans is what comes
from that question.
So if we don't actually have
empathy and like from the start,
making assumption that there's
no difference between us
and that we can't
consider people
from different backgrounds
as like, oh, I can't relate--
which actually takes me to
another story by the way.
I have to jump around.
I tell the story a lot
because it's kind of important.
I was once at the bookstore
and there was a little
white girl reading
"The Mighty Miss Malone"--
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Oh, yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: -- which
is a great book
and has a little beautiful
little black girl on the cover.
And this girl was like in--
She's reading this book.
I mean, she's like
several chapters
and she has broken the binding.
I mean, I'm sitting
there thinking they need
to buy this book, right?
But then, her mother comes
over and takes the book
out of her hand and says, no
honey, that book is not for you.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
That happens a lot.
>> Ellen Oh: It happens a lot.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
I've had that so many times.
Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
So, what is the message
that that child took away?
I'm not-- I don't
think that-- Sorry.
I don't think that
the mom is racist,
but I think her actions were.
I think it was unintentional.
And I think that's
what we have to talk
about is systemic
racism, systemic bias
that we've kind of-- the
biases that we've internalized
without even knowing about it.
>> Meg Medina: I think
about that with the titles
of my books sometimes.
You know, I have Spanish
in the title a lot,
"Tia Isa Wants a Car,"
"Mango, Abuela, and Me."
So it's very identifiable,
right?
You can pretty much
piece it together.
And I have in my more insecure
moments wondered about someone
like that standing in front of
the book and making a decision
about who gets to
read this book.
So-- And I think that
that's a real question.
I mean, I've certainly met
librarians who will say,
sometimes, we don't have very
many Latinos in my school
so we don't really buy that
many books about Latinos.
I've had, you know,
conversations that
run like that.
>> Ellen Oh: They
don't have any dragons
in their neighborhood either.
>> Meg Medina: Right,
right, right.
>> Ellen Oh: They
don't have any hobbits.
>> Meg Medina: Right.
>> Ellen Oh: They don't
have any talking gorillas.
>> Meg Medina: They don't.
They don't.
But, you know, my feeling
is that if you don't,
that's why you need my books
more than anybody else.
>> Ellen Oh: Exactly.
>> Meg Medina: But I
do feel like that plays
into just what you're saying.
So, that's just an--
that's an example of--
you know, like a simple bias
that has really wide-reaching
repercussions.
>> Ellen Oh: Exactly.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
Or even in publishing, I've
had conversations with editors
and agents who will
say, I really--
I care about diverse literature.
I want diverse authors
or diverse books,
but they don't come across
my desk, or they don't come
to me is basically the message.
And the idea that, OK, maybe
you need to go out and look
or do some extra work is
really difficult for a lot
of people to understand.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah, yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Which takes me to
the next question, which I have
to go back, right here.
OK. So first of all, this
quote "We live in a world
where the forces that seek
to divide us are strong.
To overcome them, we must do
more than simply stand next
to one another in silence."
I love this quote
because it talks--
to me, it takes us to
the point that right now,
you're seeing the rise
of the author activist.
So, I know why it's
important for me.
I'd love Meg for you
to talk about it too.
>> Meg Medina: Well,
what I would say is
that I don't have the luxury of
stepping out of who I am, right?
So, a Latina woman, this is
the experience I have, and so,
I don't feel like I can
turn my back on that.
And I also feel like I just
can't see a way to do this work,
publishing right now in this
time with this opportunity
that is available to us
to really reshape how we're
thinking about these books
without doing some
heavy lifting.
So, I have this thing
that I've been talking
about called radical
abundance, right?
Abundance is such a pretty word.
It just sounds nice, right?
And radical sort
of speaks to me.
So, radical abundance
is my desire
to certainly promote my own work
and my own creative development.
That's great.
But also, to make room at the
table for new authors who come.
And the story that I often
use is my mother-in-law used
to always say-- she had
this really ugly little--
really ugly little
dining room table.
It's a little round
thing, 42 inches.
But the strangest thing
about this table is
that if four people were sitting
there eating, we all fit.
If six people were
eating, we still fit.
If eight people were
eating, we were all there,
cutting small, but
we were there.
So, it's amazing, right?
And she used to say, in Spanish,
esta mesa se estira
como un chicle,
meaning this table
stretches like a piece of gum.
And I love that.
And so, I feel like
it's important for us
to stretch the table
like a piece of gum.
So-- And it's easy,
it's fairly easy to do.
So like when I'm invited to
NCTE to do a roundtable talk,
my response is now, not
just, sure, I'd love to.
My response is, I'd love to, do
you mind if I also bring Juana,
so and so whose new book
is blah, blah, blah?
If somebody is asking me to
blur books, I don't blur books,
but I say I do other things,
can we do a shared thing
on my blog or an event?
So, that I'm introducing
somebody else.
And I ask librarians and
teachers all the time
to take a risk on new
authors coming to the table.
You can invite the
six big Latino authors
over and over again.
We'd love to come.
But there's more of us, right?
So, pair us maybe, somebody
well-known with somebody new.
And that's the radical
abundance.
Now, the pushback that
I've gotten on it is this.
From a very well-known author
who I respect immensely,
she said to me, we're
at a conference,
she said, but is that fair?
She said, I have been at this
for 25 years and I was told,
I'm sorry, I can't take
your book onto my list
because we already
have an author
of this background, et cetera.
And, you know, she's
very accomplished now
and she just feels like, is it
really fair to ask me after all
of that work that I did to do--
to keep doing this
now for you too?
And I said it is not fair.
But, you know, as my mother
always said, what ifs, right?
And so, nothing is fair,
but that's the job, man.
And so, that's what I say.
So, I am encouraging you to
embrace radical abundance
and to certainly don't
forget about my books.
I really do want to come
to your schools and so on,
but to take risks on new voices,
and if I'm promoting a new
voice, to bother to pick
up their book and see
what that's about.
Because in the end,
like nobody is forever.
You're not forever.
I'm not forever.
I'm going to have my day in the
sun and I'm thrilled for it,
and it may be this day, right?
But it's not forever.
And it's important
to stretch the table.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
What makes that uncomfortable?
>> Ellen Oh: No, you can't just
say what Megs that [laughter].
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
What makes that--
>> Meg Medina: How do
you stretch the table?
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: I mean,
I think it's stretching the
table and also all of us,
like it doesn't have to just
be authors as activists,
librarians as activists,
teachers as activists.
Like all of us figuring out
in our space what we can do.
And that really leads me to
talking about how sometimes
that also leads to moments
or seasons of discomfort.
>> Ellen Oh: Ah, wait, wait.
Hold on. We have a
good one for this.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: I do?
>> Ellen Oh: Yes [laughter].
I am uncomfortable.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
It does look terrible
[laughter], poor dog.
But we-- I feel like we--
so I mean, I do avoid
feeling uncomfortable
and avoid discomfort.
And as a-- When I first
started out as a literacy,
whatever I was supposed to
be a literacy instructor,
as a college freshman, I had
this experience of our job being
to basically walk around these
neighborhoods in New York City
and knock on people's door, it's
cold, and sort of be like, hey,
I'm Olugbemisola and
I'm here to talk to you
about nutrition and literacy.
And it was this family
literacy program where we talked
about recipes and
grocery shopping as a way
to engage parents in
literacy activities
and then we read to children.
So, I had no idea
what I was doing.
And I don't even know how we
got that job, like that day.
But-- And we had a lot of
uncomfortable experiences
and I had to work through them.
I had an experience on my
very last day when I told one
of the students in the
family that I would take her
to the museum because she
had never been to the Museum
of Natural History in New York.
And so I was like, oh, I'll
take you to the museum.
And her mom says that it was OK.
I came to pick her up
on that day, I'm 18,
and there were 17
other kids [laughter]
who would come for
this museum trip.
They had like called everybody.
>> Ellen Oh: Field
trip [laughter].
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yes.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh god.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
I'm freaking out [laughter].
What am I going to do?
And so like we went to
the museum and luckily,
the Natural History has
suggested admissions.
So, I think I paid like
a dime for everybody.
And then I had said we
would go to pizza afterward.
And we went to this one place
that I didn't realize was
like kind of high-end pizza.
So, we went in and sat
down and drank our water.
And then when I saw the menu, I
was like, guys, we have to get
up and go because I
didn't have enough money.
So, I say all this to
say that was discomfort.
And sometimes when we don't
want to stretch ourselves
or have these conversations,
we're thinking more
about our own discomfort than
about our readers, our students,
our-- the-- our communities
and our populations.
And we're thinking
about not knowing--
being afraid of being in
a position of not knowing
or of losing authority
or of losing control.
And I think we have
to understand
that sometimes we're not going
to know and we're going to have
to be in a position to tell
students or tell people,
you know, I really don't know.
Or think about doing
things a different way.
I worked with a school that
had a book club for a long time
that was a Newbery, sort
of Mock Newbery book club.
Then one year, I did the
book club, but it was--
we called it a Social
Justice Book Club.
And what we did with
fifth graders was say, OK,
you guys have a mission.
There are a lot of
books in this library
that nobody ever checks out.
Let's go through and
analyze the shelves.
First, let's think about
what we have in this library
and why we think it's here.
Is it because the adults love
these books when they were kids
and just keep putting the
same books in the library?
So, there was that issue that we
talked about with the students.
And then, we pulled books
and said, OK, your mission is
to read and share these
books with your peers.
These are books that you
might think are great
after you read them, but
nobody is reading them.
So, how can we share these
books and get them circulating?
So, the kids felt like
they had a mission
and that they were
doing something
to promote diverse books
in their community.
And sometimes, we pulled books--
the librarians and I pulled
books that all the kids
in the club were like,
yeah, we don't like this.
And we-- So, they
had space to say,
we don't like this,
and here's why.
You guys can try reading it.
Good luck with that, but
this isn't our thing.
And we just left that
space open to do that.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: I think
the discomfort thing
from the adult perspective
is this.
I just had this talk at the
North Texas Teen Book Festival
and that's that-- you're going
to-- you're in this room,
we're all locked in this like
little suite bubble, right?
This is not where the
heavy lifting happens.
The heavy lifting happens
when you are at a meeting
with someone who you admire
very much and you have to point
out that a book on the shelf
is hurtful for x, y or z reason
or you have to disagree about
the selection of the book
or you have to point
out some bias.
Like that's where
the heavy lifting is.
Isn't it Neville who says
this in Harry Potter,
he gets that award for
standing up to his friends
in the first book
of Harry Potter?
Like that's the award you
need to get people, right,
because that's where the
heavy lifting is, right?
That's where the discomfort is.
The discomfort also comes for me
when I'm asking myself harder
questions as I'm writing.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: So just
"Merci Suarez Changes Gears,"
we were like in the late
stages, right, of pages.
And, you know, I talk about
diversity all the time.
Of course, I'm sensitive.
Of course, I'm above making
any kind of mistake, blah.
So, here's what happens, right?
I'm reading through my pages,
looking for commas and so on,
and I see this line
that Merci says.
She's talking to her brother
and he's ignoring her.
And she says, so Roli
plays death and what--
you know, blah, blah,
blah, and it goes on.
And I thought about that.
I said, huh, well,
there's no problem saying
that unless you are a
person who's hard of hearing
or has hearing trouble.
And then, it feels really lousy
to have somebody
saying playing death.
So, I struck it out and
I wrote something else.
And I felt icky for being
a person who had made
such a gross error, I guess.
But I took the time to pause
and I ask myself hard questions.
And the frustration
I have sometime is
when authors don't take
that pause, and they assume
that they have the
right tell any story
and they don't necessarily
have the respect or the nuance
or the understanding to tell it.
>> Ellen Oh: Right.
>> Meg Medina: And then, they
hurt people and then you're
in a position of
trying to explain why.
That I find exhausting.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: Do you
find it exhausting?
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh yeah.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: We have
to be comfortable
with being uncomfortable.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Right?
And I know that's hard.
Nobody likes being
uncomfortable, right?
It's like having a
perpetual wedgie.
It's not comfortable [laughter].
But--
>> Meg Medina: Like spanks.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: Emotional spanks.
>> Ellen Oh: Exactly.
You just--
>> Meg Medina: Not that
we know [laughter].
>> Ellen Oh: That's a
constipated look, Meg.
Sorry.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Anyway.
But for me, I think the
conversations are so important.
And I'll just give
you an example.
I was at an event and
somebody came to me
and had taken screenshots of
my Facebook page at a time
when I was very upset
about certain things
that had politically
happened in the world
and might have used
some language
that might have been
very problematic.
And so, they shared with me
my screenshots and told me
that I was anti-white,
that I was promoting white
genocide because, you know,
talking about diversity
in children's literature
promotes white genocide.
I don't actually get
that connection myself.
But this is the idealogy
that was coming at me.
And if I had been 20 years
later, we would had a, you know,
a showdown in the
parking lot, right?
But age has mellowed me.
And I was able to say
to her, you're right,
I actually made a mistake.
I shouldn't have used
such incendiary language.
I wouldn't do it again.
And then, I hope she
would actually sit
down because she'd accused me
of having an LGBT agenda also.
And I said, I hope she would
sit down and actually listen
to my presentation and
talk to me about it.
And she did.
And this woman, who was so
angry and thought all these
like horrible things about
diversity, actually came
up to me after the presentation
and said, you're right,
I see your point,
we do need diversity
in children's literature.
And she gave me a hug.
So like, this was
a conversation.
Of course, I was actually the
only one talking during the
presentation, but she listened.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
And that happened I think
because you were willing
to say you're right,
I made a mistake.
>> Ellen Oh: Exactly.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
And it was so hard for us to say
I made a mistake or I'm sorry.
And so just accept that
and acknowledge it rather
than figure out ways to get
around it and justify it.
>> Ellen Oh: Exactly.
Yeah. I would also
like to get to a point
where racism isn't a dirty word
and that people don't react
to being called a racist
with that, you know,
that like jerk reaction of
how dare you call me a racist.
Like it's some kind of
fighting words kind of thing.
And instead, why don't we
treat it like it's an illness?
Why don't we treat it like
it is a disease that we,
as a community, as a society,
have to work together to come
up with a solution
and resolve it
because it's systemic,
it's on everything.
And if we don't actually work
together to address that issue,
it's just going to continue.
All we'll do is kind of
band-aid over the problem.
What were you saying,
people will just try
to game the system, you know?
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
Game the system.
So, change the system.
>> Ellen Oh: Exactly.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
So, uncomfortable
conversations, like with--
sometimes with family
too, right?
So-- But what is next for us?
Like what--
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
I-- You know, what would
3.0 look like, right?
So, 2.0 looks like
to me advocacy
and staying with the discomfort.
And, you know, I have this
really superficial connection,
which is I'm trying
to grow out my hair.
OK. Let's just go to this.
And my hairdresser, I sat
in the chair three days ago
and I said, cut it all out.
I wanted to cut again because
I can't stand this anymore.
And she said to me as a good
hairdresser will, no, no.
She said, I'm going to walk you
through this plateau [laughter].
And I said, all right.
And some of you are like,
we're talking about hair,
how did we say like, you
know, but stay with me people.
OK. So she said, no, no, we
will walk through this plateau.
She said, I know it doesn't
feel like what you want to--
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And this is just hair.
It's the most superficial thing.
But we're like in the plateau.
So, we have to stay
together and walk
through this uncomfortable
plateau, this ugly phase
of being uncomfortable,
of learning to have
delicate conversations
and not deferring
always to being--
no, I don't want to say
deferring to be polite
because I do believe
in politeness.
I do believe in offering
each other grace.
I do believe in offering each
other respect always even
when we're having
hard conversations.
But don't defer to silence.
>> Ellen Oh: Yes.
>> Meg Medina: Just standing
next to each other silently--
>> Ellen Oh: Don't
be the bystander.
>> Meg Medina: -- and
thinking things without saying.
>> Ellen Oh: I think the
bystander effect is something
that we all have to
continue to recognize.
Even I do it sometimes, right,
where you just feel too awkward
and too uncomfortable
to confront a situation
that you know is problematic.
Sometimes, it's because it's
dangerous and you're scared,
which actually self-preservation
is always first, of course.
But if it's-- if there
is safety, I think it's--
you know, we can't
be bystanders.
We have to have the
conversation.
We have to tell that racist
uncle that they're being racist,
or you're mocker or something.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
But even approaching--
As a parent, sometimes
approaching schools
about their book list
or their curricula.
And one thing that I guess
3.0ish that we've seen is
that schools have been
approaching WNDB and saying,
we want to review-- do
a curriculum review.
And there are books that we know
that our community holds dear
that there are likely other
books that could replace them
or be added to the curricula,
but we need to figure out how
to have this conversation
with our community,
but we're willing
to figure that out.
We're willing to have
these conversations.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: We have--
There's a book that
a lot of people love,
that when I was a kid and read
it, I did not like at all,
"To Kill a Mockingbird."
And it was a book that I
had heard so much about
and just was supposed
to be so great.
And so when I read
it, I was furious
because I did not
like it at all.
And it's a lot of
peoples' favorites
and on a lot of curricula.
And for my daughter, when
it was on her curricula
in the middle school, and when
she first got it, I was like,
oh yeah, I hate that book.
And we talked a little
bit about why,
but I didn't really
talk too much about it
because she was going
to read it herself.
So, I wanted her to-- so she
came up feeling some type of way
after she read it, and--
but was able to articulate
that to her teacher
and in her classroom.
And then, I guess, you know,
the school is kind of like
where that come from, or
we're progressive school,
we're already doing all
these wonderful things and--
but was able to sort of
have this conversation
within the discussion of
the book of who has power
in the story, who has
agency in the story,
what is-- what does this mean.
So while the book as far
as I know is still part
of that curriculum, at
least there's a willingness
to discuss it and discuss
why and think about everyone
in the community and how
these stories affect everyone,
not just the people who
are like, this is classic
and it's been here
and I love it.
>> Meg Medina: The Washington
Post just had a fantastic piece
on "Challenging the Canon."
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: So, I
encourage you to look that up.
It was within a week
or two, I think.
It was really wonderful.
So the 3.0 thing I'd like to--
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
So schools are doing it.
>> Meg Medina: Oh, I'm sorry.
The other 3.0 thing is
I'm always interested
in who's still missing a table.
And so within Latino
literature, I will tell,
I would like to see more
authors from Honduras,
from El Salvador,
from other countries.
If you want to understand
this situation
that we're facing right now with
immigration, with our borders
and so on, you have to know that
history to see how we got here.
We need more Afro-Latino
authors at the table.
So, those are two areas that
I think within Latino kidlet,
I'd like to see more
of in there.
>> Ellen Oh: We definitely
need more native First Nations
writers, indigenous writers
writing about their own cultures
because their voice is missing.
I mean, we have a few.
We need more, right?
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
People with disabilities too.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
The story of the people with
disabilities that are not--
well, and all these cases
that are not problem stories,
but stories about
people living rich
and full lives in their own way.
>> Ellen Oh: I mean, I
have two kids that suffer
from crippling depression.
And they are always looking
for the books that isn't
about suicide or that
glamorizes suicide.
What is with that, right?
We need the books that show
them that it's OK, you can--
you know, you can live
and be successful even
with mental disease.
We also need-- Like for me,
Asian-American Pacific
Islander is this great big
like amalgam, right?
Let's talk about
how big that is.
And we tend to focus on
East Asian writing the most,
East and Southeast
Asian writers.
We don't have enough
Pacific Islander, right,
authors being published.
We're not hearing their voice.
So, I do think there's a lot
of holes there that
we need to fill.
But I think now, we
have time for questions
because I see people
wanting to ask.
So, can we now have questions?
Yes? Would you like to ask?
>> I just wanted to know
because you talked bout the way
[inaudible] and someone spoke
to you about your Facebook post
and then you spoke about
your daughter being able
to articulate and have these
types of conversations,
and I'm wondering how
do you teach people not
to be bystanders and voice
their concerns articulately
without being incendiary.
And then also, how do you
speak so that people want
to have understanding and
compassionate conversations
because people do get on
the defense when you bring
up racism or bias or bigotry.
So, how do you have
compassionate,
understanding conversations?
>> Ellen Oh: So, you know
how like you have a--
if you get an email and you
get really, really angry,
you're at work, you got
an email, it makes you mad
and it's probably your
boss and you get really mad
and you start typing
a really angry email,
but you don't hit send
because, self-preservation.
You don't want to
get fired, right?
That-- You know,
that split second
where you recognize what you're
going to say is going to be bad,
that's what saved me in
so many conversations,
that I've had the ability
to stop, to bite my tongue,
to push back the defensiveness
by the way, which usually
that comes up, or the anger,
and then try to engage them
in a conversation and
deflate their anger.
So when-- like for example,
when somebody is called a
racist, they get mad, right?
How do you then address
the issue without getting
that first gut reaction?
For me, it's always been to
kind of like be the calmer one,
but in kind and gentle and say,
I understand why you're
upset by hearing this.
Let's talk about those feelings.
And I think that that's-- you
have to come with compassion
because if you're just too
confident, they get mad
because they're like, oh,
you think you're
better than me, right?
So, it's kind of like that,
you know, being compassionate
and empathetic while trying to
have a difficult conversation.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich:
And I think one thing--
like for my daughter,
one thing that was--
she's fortunate with is that
she has always had school
experiences from the very
beginning where they--
that kind of social-emotional
learning
and those effective
communication lessons were
always a part from kindergarten.
And so, a resource that I
would recommend is the--
I love the Morningside Center
for teaching social
responsibility.
And I use those.
So the things that-- when I
used to work with first graders
and second graders and
fifth graders on how
to have these hard conversations
and talk in circles,
or the things that sometimes
when my daughter was little
and would come home and I would
kind of roll my eyes, like yeah,
yeah, yeah, nobody really
talks like this, like OK, OK.
But I see how they work and
I see how when children have
that as part of their
education at school and--
I mean, I'm fortunate that
I can reinforce it at home.
But using those kind of lessons,
I use them all the time.
When I-- Like the lessons
for elementary schoolers,
I can go back and look at these
when I know that I'm going to be
in a situation where
I might have
to have a challenging
conversation.
Literally go back and look at
those lessons for teachers or--
of any age and think
about how I can apply them
in the conversations
I'm going to have.
>> Meg Medina: I--
I'm going to just butt
in because I'm remembering
Tim Tingle.
We did one of our
first conferences here
at the Library of Congress.
It was talking about family
through the multicultural lens,
like various people, how do
we see and write about family.
And Ellen was on that panel,
but so as Tim Tingle
who's a Choctaw author.
And he said to a very
similar question,
I remember that I am
meeting them on the bridge
that they are crossing.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, yeah.
That's right.
>> Meg Medina: And I
never forgot those words
because when I'm
talking with someone
who has a very deeply different
point of view or a point of view
that I find hurtful or
just small in some way.
I try to remember that
they're on a journey, right?
And I'm going to try to be there
and help them cross that bridge.
They won't all, and that's sad.
But you know what,
it's also true,
I'm on a journey crossing
a bridge for somebody else.
There are going to be
moments that I make a mistake
or I am not the most
empathetic and I hope
that I'm greeted with grace.
And I get a lot of stuff for
that, like for being too soft
on people sometimes,
and I understand.
But I think that if we allow the
conversation to just spiral up
and get really terse,
we stop listening.
It's like when my husband
and I fight, right?
Like who's listening, right?
So, like we got to calm.
We got to go to the
ice cream parlor
and share a hot fudge sundae or
something and then we can get
to the bottom of things,
which tells you how our
family runs [laughter].
>> Ellen Oh: I also think
sometimes that you might feel
like the conversation
is not going anywhere,
but you never know.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: You plant
those seeds wherever you can
so that you're not
the bystander,
that you have those
moments where you just kind
of provide somebody with
a different perspective.
And that maybe, that will become
a growing lesson for them.
You won't see it, but maybe
somebody else will 10 years
from now.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah.
That happens a lot.
>> Ellen Oh: Right, yeah.
Any other questions?
>> Meg Medina: I think that
it's close to their drain time.
>> Ellen Oh: I know, right?
>> Meg Medina: They're all
like, I've got to get to eat.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Yeah, yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Well, if
there's no questions,
should we just wrap it up?
>> Meg Medina: Thank you
so much for having us.
>> Olugbemisola
Rhuday-Perkovich: Thank you.
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Guy Lamolinara:
Thanks so much
to the panelists here
today, to all our panelists.
You provided us with
so many great topics
for future conversations
and things to think about.
So, could we have
a round of applause
for all the panelists
[applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.